Young Max, one more offense,
and you'll be behind bars.
Flora, you're his mother…
Find him something to do.
What are you doing right now?
You don't want to know.
You are a great mother.
Am I?
Happy birthday.
- What's that?
- It's yours.
Don't want to play.
Since when am I a guitarist?
I can't go on like this,
living in a shoebox
with a kid who hates me.
Can't wait for the day
I don't have to be here.
Go on!
Go back to your dad!
I might learn the guitar myself.
That's just too funny.
Takes years of practice,
commitment.
Are you really gonna talk to me
about commitment?
We're ready to teach you
how to shred the gnar on guitar.
So, you wanna learn the guitar.
This is a gift you can
take to your grave.
- What's your problem?
- I didn't know I had a problem.
You're teaching guitar
online, Love.
What are you hoping
to get out of this?
I thought this guitar
might make my son
think I'm cool.
- I'll be back in an hour!
- I don't care.
- How annoying is he?
- Very annoying.
- What is that?
- Shh.
Jesus Christ,
it's like a club in here!
Turn it down a second!
Was that yours?
How did you make that?
It sounded epic.
♪ Come on girl, let's get in trouble ♪
♪ Shaken, not stirred
A James Bond from Dublin ♪
♪ We got something real ♪
Why don't you ask her out?
Can I try that on?
- It's too big.
- That's the look.
Yeah, for turtles.
She's totally
out of my league.
Let's write a song.
She has to hear your passion.
Express yourself.
She hated it.
Yo, just get out of my way,
woman.
Gladly!
I was 17 with a
screaming child on my lap.
This can't be my story.
But, without him,
I have nothing.
♪
How come the way things are
are never enough for you?
♪
They never were.
Playing the guitar…
it's so sexy.
Okay.
Is that why you took it up?
Let's focus on you.
Are you coming on to me?
♪